the major causes of morbidity and
mortality among American teenagers are
self-inflicted behaviors so motor
vehicle crashes homicide suicide drug
related behaviors that lead to two
health consequences either because of
the drugs themself or because when
you're using drugs or drinking you're
more likely to have an accident get into
a fight have unprotected sex it's on so
our approach to dealing with these
problems in this country for years has
been through classroom based education
abstinence education just saying no
education and so on and and if you look
at these programs and you look at
evaluations of those programs you can't
help but come away disappointed and
perhaps even skeptical I mean there
which is all over the country doesn't
work at all and we know that from good
studies of dear abstinence only
education which has been thoroughly
evaluated doesn't work driver's
education I learned recently doesn't
work I'm so educating kids about
avoiding risky or harmful situations or
substances doesn't seem to make much of
a difference and and I think that if you
look at basic social psychology that's
not surprising because what most studies
show is that it's not hard to change
people's attitudes and knowledge but
it's really hard to change their
behavior and so in our work
we've asked well why is it that kids
know that these things are risky know
that these things are harmful and still
do them anyway I mean you know huge
proportionate kids have sex without
using condoms I mean they've been told
over and over and over again that that's
dangerous a large force to kids become
cigarette smokers regular smokers
they've been told over and over again
that that's dangerous why do they do
these things and my argument is is not
that we should stop telling them the
facts about risky behavior but that we
need to understand
that kids engage in a lot of us taking
behavior for reasons that have nothing
to do with their knowledge or beliefs
they have to do with something that I
talked about earlier which has to do
with this increase in sensation seeking
and thrill seeking that occurs during
early adolescence that has to do with
changes in the brain and it has to do
with the still maturing control system
that regulates impulses that allows us
to make better decisions and and middle
adolescents will say from 14 to 17 or so
there's a time when you have a very
easily aroused reward system which makes
you less attentive to the possible costs
of a risky decision and more attentive
to the immediate rewards so you have
this hyper arousal reward system and you
have this immature impulse control
system so kids pursue their rewards and
they don't have the brakes to you know
to put on so how can how can we address
this because clearly you know when you
were on a couch making out with your
girlfriend and you're aroused you know
if you don't have the maturity of
judgment to stop and say you know we
should use a condom before we go any
further you're going to have unsafe sex
so the the the approach I think we need
to take for many of these behaviors is
by changing the context in which kids
live not by trying to change the kid I
don't think we can change this aspect of
adolescence nor do I think we should
what do I mean by changing the context
graduated driver's licensing is a
perfect example of this it is well
established that adolescents have more
crashes when they're driving with other
adolescent passengers in the car than
when they're driving by themselves we
did a study in our lab in which we
manipulated this experimentally and
found the same thing now we're doing
brain imaging work now in which we're
seeing why this is likely to be the case
up until fairly recently there were no
restrictions on kids having passengers
in the car when they first got their
licenses well this doesn't make any
sense given what we know from the
actuarial data and from scientific
research we having passengers in the
when you're a teenager increases your
risk of having a crash - about the same
degree that drinking does so it's a
really serious risk factor for for
having a crash and most parents I think
would hesitate to turn the car keys over
to their teenager if they smelled
alcohol on her breath but would they
even ask if she was gonna pick up a
bunch of other kids and drive around
with him even though they're both risky
so graduated driver's licensing sets
restrictions early on in the licensing
process over the conditions under which
kids can drive all right that has been
very very effective in states that have
implemented it and in states where it is
enforced it we could have classroom
based education in which we told kids
you know if you have your friends in the
car it's gonna increase the likelihood
of an accident and I'll bet that they
wouldn't change their behavior at all
but but if but having a law that says
they can't do it they can lose their
license if they drive that way that has
shown to be effective and that's what I
mean by changing the context rather than
trying to change the kid